(audience rhythmically clapping)
- [Announcer] Saw him the 16th
of February at the Aberdeen.
Please, build up, build up, build up
and welcome to the stage,
the wonderful Chris Turner!
(audience cheering)
- Guys over here, what would
you like to hear a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Kim Jong-un.
- [Chris] Kim Jong-un?
(audience laughing)
If you were older, I would fight you.
That's a great suggestion.
Touch me down.
There we go, Kim Jong-un.
You a fan?
I should check, do you like him?
(audience murmuring)
Your buddy does.
Your buddy's nodding
his head, like "Yeah!"
He's got a pretty spiffy haircut.
I like it, cool.
Kim Jong-un, for those
of you that don't know,
he is the leader of North Korea,
which, ask your parents to take
you on holiday, it's great.
(audience laughing)
Kim Jong-un is the first suggestion.
Guys over here, what would
you like to hear a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Hang gliding.
- Hang gliding, are
you a hang glider, sir?
Why did the person next
to you, you just went.
(audience laughing)
That's just ridiculous.
Okay, cool, what would you suggest?
Your mum (laughs)?
Great, the suggestion is
"your mum hang gliding."
Great, we'll combine
those, make it better.
Don't know what I would have
expected talking to a teenager.
Right, guys over here,
what would you guys like
to hear a rap about?
(audience murmuring)
- [Audience Member] Bad hair day.
- [Chris] Bad hair day, is
that a pointed attack on me?
(audience laughing)
I'm a man, we don't have bad hair day,
we just have days, right?
Kim Jong-un, your mum hang
gliding, a bad hair day.
You put your hand up there,
do you have a suggestion?
Or are you saying,
"I'm having a pretty
great hair day, Chris."
Your hair's on point, buddy.
I like it, bad hair day.
Bad hair day, your mum
hang gliding, Kim Jong-un.
Guys over here, what do you
want to hear a rap about?
- [Audience Members] Netball!
- [Chris] Wow, some real,
either you've got a psychic link
or there was some discussion before that.
Netball, are you all on netball team?
- [Audience Member] Yeah!
- [Chris] Cool, what
positions do you play?
- [Audience Member] W.D.
- [Chris] W.D., you say that as if I know
what those letters stand for.
Wing defence?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- [Chris] Cool.
Are you impressed that a man knew
what netball positions are?
My mum played netball, professionally,
which means she didn't really get paid
'cause no one watches it,
'cause it's not a real sport.
- [Audience Members] Oh!
- Just saying it, guys!
No, netball is an amazing sport.
It's a great suggestion.
Netball, specifically
playing wing defense,
Your mum hang gliding,
bad hair day, Kim Jong-un.
I'm gonna take one final suggestion.
This can come from anywhere,
but it has to be the best one so far,
you can't let the side down,
'cause so far they've been pretty good.
- [Audience Member] Diamonds
on the soles of my shoes!
- Diamonds on the sole of your shoes?
(audience laughing)
Netball must pay pretty well, then.
Great, diamonds on the
soles of your shoes.
That, genuinely, is one of
the most fantastic suggestions
I've had in Perth, which
is not really saying much,
but I like it.
Your suggestions, to remind you all,
Kim Jong-un, your mum hang
gliding, bad hair day,
netball, specifically wing defense,
and diamonds on the sole of my shoes.
(audience laughing)
I mean, if that's what you laugh at,
you are gonna love the next three minutes.
It's gonna be amazing.
As I said, this is a freestyle rap,
made up entirely on the spot,
never to be seen again,
never been seen before.
And do not worry, it
will not be anywhere near
as atrociously, embarrassingly,
toe-curlingly bad
as you are expecting a privately educated,
middle-class, white British boy to be.
(audience murmuring)
That is about 150 people
going, "We are not convinced."
(audience laughing)
No worries.
DJ, if we could drop that beat,
let's show them how we do.
(bass thrumming)
I'm excited for this, even if
only about seven of you are.
Maybe we should start with
the netball one first,
just to get the enthusiasm up.
Cool.
♪ When it comes to sports,
I was on the fence ♪
♪ But then I started playing
in on the wing defense ♪
♪ Never attack or guarding
I just stand still ♪
♪ 'Cause you can't dribble with the ball ♪
♪ Where's the thrill ♪
♪ Where's the point in that ♪
♪ Yes, I must anoint ♪
♪ And netball coach tells
me to score the points ♪
♪ I try and dump through the
basket, what do you get ♪
♪ It's just a rim on the
backboard, never a net ♪
♪ But no backboard, you
can't even do a layup ♪
♪ Talk about netball all
of this is made up ♪
♪ You got how many players
on a netball team? ♪
♪ Three, four or five, come
on, help me out, team ♪
♪ What was the number,
you're looking so angry ♪
♪ Nine, that's really
crazy, don't understand me ♪
♪ How do you fit that many on the court ♪
♪ You need to expand the borders,
and I've been taught that ♪
♪ If you make a lot of
money, then what do you do? ♪
♪ You go and buy some precious gemstones ♪
♪ And put them on your shoes ♪
♪ Why upon the sole,
where no one can see ♪
♪ Unless you walk around
the city skipping ♪
♪ And then you lift your shoes
up, they see them glistening ♪
♪ I've got the VVS, everybody listens in ♪
♪ It means very, very
significant (slight) inclusions ♪
♪ They're very expensive,
I've got a solution ♪
♪ Conduct a heist, break
into the bank at night ♪
♪ And make sure you don't get
caught by the search lights ♪
♪ So how do I exit in the air ♪
♪ You can look up and
see me on a hang glider ♪
♪ But there, I am not the only one ♪
♪ I'm joined by someone
else, and it's your mum ♪
♪ Apparently, we be going
side to side though ♪
♪ So close on the handle,
we're touching elbows ♪
♪ I say, Yo, Mum, what do you think ♪
♪ She says, I like Pinot
Grigio, it's my favorite drink ♪
♪ It is irrelevant, now
we're gonna steal gemstones ♪
♪ She goes, don't worry, I
brought a glass from home ♪
♪ She's sipping up when
we're flying up there ♪
♪ It's like we're levitating
in the air without a care ♪
♪ And then we touchdown and
we're feeling all right ♪
♪ But then my mum says,
oh, put up a fight ♪
♪ I should've brought dry
shampoo and hairspray ♪
♪ Why, because she's
suffering a bad hair day ♪
♪ She didn't comb it properly,
didn't even wash it ♪
♪ I pull out some Batiste
that I got in my pocket ♪
♪ I spray it on liberally,
it looks like talc ♪
♪ She rubs it in, it
goes inside her scalp ♪
♪ The keratin molecules
inside her hair follicles ♪
♪ Grow so long and lustrous
and they'll follow, y'all ♪
♪ To one guy, he never understands ♪
♪ Kim Jong-un, bad hair in Korean lands ♪
♪ North of the border, its a cliché ♪
♪ He never grooms himself
properly for uniform games ♪
♪ All of his soldiers,
they stand and salute ♪
♪ They're forced to say,
Kim, you look real cute ♪
♪ Not as much as your
dad, he had the skills ♪
♪ He had much better
hair, yeah, Kim Jong-il ♪
♪ No one wants to clear for
that, he was a bad guy ♪
♪ Sent people to the gulags
and watched them die ♪
♪ But how do you even
know that the guy exists ♪
♪ You're like, seven years
old and love politics ♪
♪ The smartest kid that
you will see here today ♪
♪ Off to North Korea on a holiday ♪
♪ But one little fact that
you must remind yourself ♪
Don't do like Otto Warmbier
and steal that sign.
There you go!
(audience cheering)
(audience whistling)
- [Chris] Thank you very much!